those one for every member state these
are the judges of the Court of Justice
of the European Union followed by eleven
advocates general the environment
economic and Monetary Affairs
competition employment and Social
Affairs research and innovation health
and many other areas are regulated by EU
law it's the same in all Member States
the judges clarify the interpretation of
union law when requests are made to them
by national course or by colleagues they
also deal with certain cases concerning
annulment and appeals other judges the
system through the General Court in
cases concerning annulment brought by
individuals companies and in some cases
by member states the cases they handle
concern most often trade competition law
trademarks agriculture or state aid they
also deal with disputes between the EU
and its staff with a continuously
increasing caseload who's a backlog to
be cleared 600 cases a year before 2010
grew to 912 in 2014 at the end of 2015
an unprecedented twelve hundred and
seventy cases were pending new judges
will progressively reinforce defendant
court in September 2019 each member
state should have two judges and
maintain equal gender parity
this way the court should be able to
reach his decisions in a timely manner
as required by the Charter of
Fundamental Rights